we have a david pakman show subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT some
very interesting posts on the subreddit
that i noticed this morning the first a
question should Democrats abandon
Florida and what the poster argues is
that it's clear that the state is never
going to turn out for Democrats it's
also clear that Democrats waste a lot of
money on Florida and they never win so
should Democrats abandon Florida and
focus on purple states and blue states I
totally disagree Florida is a purple
state Florida is a state that Democrats
do sometimes win in and yeah I sort of
half jokingly mentioned yesterday in our
post-election wrap-up that it seems in
Florida you can run anybody against
anybody and you'll end up or somewhere
between half a point and two and a half
points apart and that that can be
frustrating but I think Florida given
Florida's population and thus the number
of electoral votes the number of
congressional districts it would be a
massive mistake for Democrats to abandon
Florida and I just disagree with the
premise that Democrats can't win in
Florida they have one in Florida many
times also from the david pakman show
subreddit this is i love this a user who
goes by pepperoni pizza bagels posted
i'm quite possibly the only registered
democrat in my area they changed my
polling location they changed my polling
location every election so now it's a 21
mile round trip from my home they'll
never suppress my vote I love it I
absolutely love it and I think it's also
a good reminder that you know I I live a
one minute walk literally a one minute
walk from where I vote here in Boston
and so many of us take for granted what
it takes to just go and vote and we have
absolutely no understanding of what's
going on elsewhere in the country and so
when we hear about polling locations
closed I mean if you shut down my
polling location and the five other
closest polling locations that probably
extends my commute to vote to a five
minute drive right so like
we're in a different universe than
what's going on in much of the United
States and that's why this is such a key
and important issue and I really
appreciate the post and the fact that
this person is voting pepperoni pizza
bagels alright and lastly from the david
pakman show subreddit playback speed at
which speed do you play the david pakman
show podcast or youtube videos you know
pat it never occurred to me that someone
might be listening to us on like 2x
playback speed but some people are and I
don't know if I should be offended or if
it should be sort of a compliment that
we're communicating so clearly that even
at double speed people are able to take
in everything that we're saying I think
people are just busy and they want to be
as efficient as possible I know when I
have to listen to some Trump rambling
speech or like a State of the Union by
him I always play that at 2x speed but
no whenever I watch back the show I
actually slow it down I do it at 0.5
times the speed because I want to
capture every second of it yeah Pat
doesn't want to miss any details in
terms of what what I what I'm saying on
the program which is very very nice you
can join the david pakman show subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink esteem slash Pakman i love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the david pakman show I'm
sure you love politics and learning and
what Blinky's does is take the best and
most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a 7 day free trial by going to
blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube i've put a link in
the video description and after
free trial if you like it and I think
you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up